cosa cosa bella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
fan di j
oggi siamo su happy with nonostante non
sia domenica in occasione del mio
compleanno non ho avuto tempo né di
editare né di registrare video racca
quindi mi voglio scusare con tutti voi e
quindi oggi se non è domenica anche se
non e domenica voglio ripartire alla
grande è perché da oggi ovviamente si
iniziava a prendere ritmo regolare
ovvero un video al giorno e forse dico
forse forse non lo so per farmi
perdonare per non aver fatto video
in sei giorni anzi di sicuro i giorni la
o domani o forse anche stasera non lo so
uscirà un secondo video di sera però che
sarà un blog speciale che non ne faccio
mai così diciamo per farvi un regalo
appunto perché sono rimasto senti in
questi giorni va beh direi di iniziare
comunque prima iniziale l'unica cosa che
vi voglio dire che in questo momento sto
utilizzando il nuovo microfono
non so se andrà a sanremo continuare a
far video adesso però vabbè è ok
fatemi soltanto sapere come si sente vi
dico soltanto che non sono ancora stato
lì a mettere a posto i settaggi non ho
capito neanche bene come funzionano
soltanto attaccato e sto provando a
registrare così come viene non ho
provato ancora a toccare nulla
ditemi se così va bene sono comunque io
prova poi a fare dei diritto occhi
eccetera
con questo non dovrebbero più darvi
fastidio le urla che faccio durante i
video quando ad esempio urlo come un
idiota non dovrebbe più darmi fastidio
alle orecchie perché prima con questa
merda dava fastidio abbastanza questo
ormai lo uso soltanto per sentire nei
videogame vabbè basta con la premessa
infinita direi di iniziare come primo
livello direi di fare
iniziamo con la world tragga siamo con
eddy devo riuscire ad iniziare come si
deve perché da un bel pezzo che non
faccio è primis quindi diremo che per
cento liuc è già andato perché se non lo
shock alcolizzato in basso a destra
e vabbè facciamo finta di niente che
intanto ci sono ci sono persone che
volano che cazzo succede
oh mio dio ho preso un pezzo ho preso
tutto veramente vabbè che cazzo succede
in alto a destra
oh mio dio grazie a dio ho preso tutto
ho preso ho preso tutto addio che cazzo
ci sono sono morti la madre e il padre
di duke e io qui ho raccolto un qualcosa
che non so bene cosa andiamo su in
prossimo però si veda un po che non ci
teniamo in allenamento lo so ma fai del
tuo meglio facciamo di vedere che anche
dopo più di una settimana di mancato è
più visto ce la facciamo se vai steve
reich che culo assurdo
vabbè lari faccio perché non penso che
ce la farò di nuovo
che culo steve siamo i più forti non ce
n'è
[Musica]
lo zio ma che cazzo no raga io e steve
ma lo sapete che io siamo troppo forti
non ce n'è cioè se c'è qualcuno che
pensa di far meglio
2 se c'è qualcuno che pensa di far
meglio di noi due si iscriva a italians
do tale ansia happy days got talent
perché vi prendono di sicuro vai vai
stime faccio la quasar è la quarta
vittoria vi assicuro che è difficile
come livello perché fa ci vuole tutta
tecnica perché se io facessi così non
funzionerebbe ci vuole tecnica ci
volessero tecnica vedete non funziona la
tecnica stan e premere il tasto destro
praticamente e mingo
vabbè faccio facciamo finta che non
abbia fatto quest'ultima parte andiamo
avanti andiamo ragazzo super bowl trovo
è da tanto che non faccio anche un volto
ci siamo con eddy ailog uk
mi sa che non hai capito proprio un
cazzo però non importa andiamo avanti
vaia disse ok perfetto bravissimo vinto
culo c'è cura turno raga vabbè ma sta
puntata iniziata da dio
raga voglio provare a fare una cosa che
non ho capito
devo andare su no no basta sono vivo
voglio riprovarci il secondo raga perché
non ho capito una cosa oddio che capo
che cazzo dio che vittoria servitori
assurdo raga questo da replay
oh mio dio che cazzo è successo 6
cazzo di vittoria è questa raga voglio
provare a fare una cosa che mi avete
consigliato nei livelli da cercare mi
avete mi avete detto di cercare fa vj
perché ce ne sono un casino avete detto
dedicati a me oh mio dio
quanti cazzo sono 37 fantastico e va
bene alcuni gli avrò già giocati di
sicuro tipo quattro al massimo gli altri
33 mi mancano ma la rassegna non sei fa
vj io è veramente non lo so veramente
non lo so ok tuo figlio non serve sonda
nale completata che cazzo è va bene
allora fatemi leggere livello ha creato
interamente per fa vige tv dei suoi
discepoli questo livello un test per
verificare se un se il tuo spettatore
sei un vero fa vj un suo discepolo per
dimostrarlo dovrei sopravvivere ok fa vj
a 15 anni ho 18 anni ok aspettate un
secondo ok ok 18 18 vai la so questa la
so ho visto le soluzioni ok perfetto ciò
si o no ma iniziata ma che cazzo sono un
genera gari esco a perdere nei quiz
incredibile c'è un genio così ma dove lo
vedete uno che riesce a perdere nei quiz
è una cosa del genere un po come morire
d'infarto a chi vuole essere milionario
praticamente vabbè andiamo avanti ci
sono ci sono ok senza un braccio ma non
importa
la leggenda narra che fa vj piaccia la
nutella o la patata ma vi prendete per
il culo cioè ok allora perfetto mai
ma cosa ma non è vero ma che cazzo 10 ma
secondo te io preferisco la nutella alla
patata amico mio non hai capito un cazzo
della vita ok la vera che facevano
contento andiamo su nutella
anche se sbagliata di gran lunga ma
andiamo avanti
ok avanzasse legge ok bravo se arrivata
alla fine di questo lunghissimo qui si
stufa vigenza significa che se un
discepolo 6 fa vj ok
ceca è finito ma mio dio c'è c'erano due
domande di cui una è sbagliata
fantastico vabbè andiamo avanti
facciamone un altro mi avete fatto
no abbiamo raga abbiamo e mix non so chi
sei ma sei un genio
allora c'è liuc che è scritto in modo
sbagliato non importano ciak si beike di
perché non ha il casco ti stimo
era lei padre di uk e santa perfetto
allora devo riuscire a primo luke baille
se basta questo lo sguardo trucco i
controcoglioni non come quello di prima
perfetto non accetto dio io faccio lo
sgambetto
ok vediamo se riesco a lanciargli una
spada nel capra anzi no perfetto l'ho
mancato del riuscito tipo ah no perfetto
soffre anche i due
meglio che non sprechi dalle tre spade
perché mi servono che i padri di york
vai anche con stipsi o dio si è bloccato
no perché si è bloccato ma edizione
cazzo si è bloccato livello ma che palle
non ci credo
manca fake ed è il perfetto il padre
l'ho preso non so neanche come va
no ma perché si blocca proprio quando
padre tirava la testata maledizione
ciamo livello per fa vj 99 che non so
che cosa non ho la più pallida idea
ok la prima è facile ho perso che cazzo
anno non ho perso perfetto vai o che ci
devo ritrovare viper madonna madonna che
però che freestyler direi di andare
avanti la che andiamo su corsa a
ostacoli
c'è il padre di uk verso il sì steve
questa è una sfida emozionante
allora no cazzo è passati a bastardo
vinco io ti tengo brutto stronzo non
passare in vantaggio
no steve maledetto è una e scorrendo
tanto non c'è l'arbitro chissenefrega
vai vai no devo riuscire a vincerla io
la edizione sta sfida devo riuscire a
cadere premi ok senza gambe raga andiamo
contro luke sono contro mio figlio ce la
farò il padre but no bastardo non passi
non può è perfetto ci abbiamo fatto
padre contro figlia mi ricordava io sono
tuo padre gli occhi perfetto non so chi
era questo ma probabilmente era
l'arbitro quindi ho vinto io ok se di
fare home jazz cioè i gesti di casa o
cazzo oh mio dio
lo ha ri
ma che cazzo di livello era questo il
mio zio era stranissimo che dovevo fare
mai mai vedere rai lancia diretti da ok
mi sono snodato una caviglia non ce l'ho
più la caviglia ok il cazzo devo
riuscire andare avanti ci posso fare vai
vai vai vai vai vai mai
porca [ __ ] è impossibile il suo
livello chat con ci devo riuscire però è
impossibile ma con bastardo prova a
cambiare personaggio vice team bye bye
bye bye della rai no ho il mio dio mio
no non ci credo che ho fatto a morire ma
che idiota
avevo vinto praticamente madonna quanto
sono idiota non ci porta a credere non
ci può fare di charlie lascia farò mai
più pazzo è stato ok
la donna una donna vai steve vai si
mancano salute po meno fatti raggiungere
se
lo capite raga perché il mio preferito
sim non ce n'è non ce n'è per nessuno
ora uran raga di hauran non ne faccio
mai amica che pronuncia epica perché non
so perché vai vai vai con gli occhi
vai con gli occhi che quello che se le
prende ma è quello che va più avanti
perfetto mi intralcia la strada luke ty
detesta maledizione
mi hai fatto perdere bastardo di merda a
letto senza cena e non ti copre figurine
dei pokémon o che guarda che bastardo
c'è un pezzo di merda che adesso minchia
lo lancio di totti
brees vivai ok e l'hanno lasciato prima
perfetto vai vai bene da lei perfetto se
addio come sto pedalando che cazzo
succede
ho vinto guardate che posizione per il
collo comodissima
va beh direi di cambiare perfetto a dare
agli allora non fanno per me ok raga
direi di cambiare salvai volte su juan
welcome to my fissa si va beh non me ne
frega niente vai
è veramente assurdo questo mi lascia
molto fare ma mio dio
sono ancora vivo sono ancora vivo sono
ancora vivo grazie mercato targa il poco
in testa come se non bastasse devo
ritrovare un secondo prestito di dio mio
dio mio dio mio dio devo che cazzo
questa volta ci sono di brutto
per noi invece se vai e ti vai vai è di
weiss ha vinto è stata un'esperienza
incredibile devo rifarlo prima o poi ma
non adesso
slow motion slow motion ok mio dio no no
che cazzo devo riuscire a resistere a e
come come faccio devo fare tifo così no
cazzo nel collo la gamba che cade
bellissimo o che vai
no non riesco a pararlo se allora ferma
ferma ok si no cazzo buon lavoravo
lavoravo lavoravo no leica pranzi e nel
collo perfetto fantastico il dem ol mi
piace come livello
[Musica]
cosa sexy
sta godendo è un addio ma che cazzo di
livello è questo fatemi capire
eva io non voglio farlo ma anche nonno
ciak sono tutti così oggi perfetto tra
andiamo avanti
niente poco lui rimane li [ __ ]
devo inchiodarlo ai 200 allora vai
si ok perfetto va il mio dio non c'è chi
ci ha preso gusto perché no
maledetto steve vai vai ok direi di
cambiare livello perché qua mi fa già
paura la bambina è rock swing con eddy
devo riuscire nona edizione
devo riuscire a farlo almeno una volta
perché
edi deve avere il suo momento diciamo sì
e per l'impossibilità ed eddy e per il
rock swing è un mito perfetto
sì non mi insegnare come si fanno i rock
swing like this
lo può fare per mio zio vai vai cos'è
grandi ora che cazzo un freestyler no
cazzo del prossimo mi servono
ok vai allora io riuscirò a finire
questo swing anche senza braccia perché
ce la posso fare
non ci credo mio dio ed è il secondo lo
swing che riesco a portare a termine
senza braccia fantastico deve soltanto
trovare gli occhi cosa cazzo sa fare che
non sa fare niente ma per il resto ci
siamo di herd bit level questo mi ispira
da dal nome you can start rete grazie
che cazzo devo stare o mio dio e lazio
dell'obeso perfetto non dovevo andare un
pochino valentini è un po un casino però
lanciarsi da una vecchia obiettivo non
taglia erba
basta ancora guidando il cazzo
va beh devo riuscire a lanciarli
o mio dio guidare il tagliaerba laica
box per madonna
usciamo di qua di elevator ok raga direi
di fare o che cazzo è questo devo devo
sopravvivere allo schianto
che cazzo dovrei riuscire a fare devo
sopravvivere è impossibile e devo
aggrapparmi qui perfetto devo aspettare
o che forse devo mai fatta non è tanto
sopravvissuto ma almeno vinto ok
perfetto
raga direi di fare look the throne level
questo mi ispira dal nome con eddy raga
direi di fare l'ultimo secret finisci
perfetto vai ho vinto io no bastardo
ok chi inizia no già sono un finto
pavimento merda merda merda
ok sono vivo nostro vivo incredibile
come fatto ho vinto
no non ho vinto ho vinto no core
allora vi bastardo ma un altro natura
meo kay questa pinar che mi stanno
crollando di brutto
ok non so come ho fatto sopravvivere
alle palle da demolizione ma ho vinto
vabbè raga direi dickey betts chamber ok
raga direi che possiamo iniziare di
nervi saldi testa su cosa facciamo
ma che cazzo mi state prendendo per il
culo c'è io ho detto testa sul collo è
no va bene quest'anno
questo è veramente pessima era una
battuta ancora prima che succedesse cioè
non ha senso voglio provare a farlo con
nonno ciak che mi sembra l'unico in
grado di riuscire a fare una roba del
genere va in una chat buy back
vai da la sedia ti serve una lista di
stupro assedia che cazzo vai vai vai vai
vai al live set
allora ce la possiamo fare sempre piano
piano bye bye bye bye da che cazzo vabbè
raga
non ci devo provare a fare oulx smash ok
l'ultimo l'ultimissimo perfetto no chao
fatta ce l'ho fatta la ferrari in tempo
vai vai babbo natale vai passato beh va
beh direi di chiudere qui raga dopo il
massacro di nonno ciak
fatemi sapere veramente come questo
microfono perché diciamo è un test nel
senso che lo proprio attaccato così come
era ho provato a registrare in teoria ci
sarebbe proprio il mixer e se volete la
marca la dirò nel blog che farò tra poco
che non sai che non sarà un normalissimo
blog nel quale parlo dei cazzi miei ma
anche dove apro dei regali che mi avete
mandato vuoi per addirittura per il
compleanno quindi veramente vi ringrazio
ma vi ringraziano a dovere nel video
fatemi comunque sapere io così almeno so
se regolarmi anno col microfono come al
solito se vi dove è piaciuto o scià
documento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora i
siti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo in un
prossimo video bella ragazzi